a lot of people be trying to do blue
steel so Ben you created the police
right so how do how do you do it what
it's a six part process uh-huh that
starts really first of all with the
thought the inception of it and secondly
it's starting to feel it in the lower
part of your body and then allowing it
to come up and then really pushing
through from the diaphragm up through
the throat and then out through the nose
mm-hmm
without thinking at all you just have to
clear your mind that's probably the
biggest thing and is it a pout or is it
up a jaw it's it's a combination of it's
really a it's there's more it's more
it's not even the the result like what
what you're doing with your face is what
you're thinking okay which is just like
okay take it already Victoria Beckham no
I mean I mean but she's got that look
right down I mean it's like yeah oh wait
yeah all the girls know how to look I'm
the right angle they go yeah
yeah joeppli though is it tight okay
okay okay okay so